on app launch I know that you're
probably tired of seeing the dummy data
and needing to hit the refresh button
for real data every single time I'm
going to show you how to display the
data using the current settings each
time the activity is loaded in
forecastfragment
we just refactor the code so that when
the refresh button is selected we call
this helper method update weather now
that it's in a helper method we can also
call it from the on start method we
override on start so that the Refresh
happens whenever the fragment starts
this will cause the weather data to
appear we'll learn all about on start
and the rest of the Android life cycle
in the next lesson at this point we can
also remove all the fake data that we
had in the on create view method then we
pass in an empty ArrayList to the array
adapter now we can test this we need to
make sure that this is the first app
launch and that it wasn't already
running so if it's already running kill
it and then tap to open the app and then
you should see the actual weather data
immediately under settings we can change
the location to be the Paris postal code
we hit OK and then return to the main
list and then we see that the weather
data has updated